[Música]
buenas noches
no veo casi nadie pero que ya sea mejor
no crean esto es bastante difícil para
todos los demás que vinieron antes que
yo yo los compadezco
y luego estoy muy feliz de estar aquí
hoy para mí un gusto es un honor
no puedo exagerar cuanto yo valoro que
estemos aquí todos juntos este espacio
para encontrarnos y para conversar
conversaron
compartir versos
compartir los poemas que nos gustan las
canciones favoritas y porque compartimos
estas cosas la verdad es para no cantar
solos la verdad es para poder cantar
juntos con otras personas la verdad que
lo hacemos es para que nos puedan hacer
el coro
mi intención estos próximos minutos es
conversar con ustedes sobre
la confianza que se requiere para
decidir a qué vas a dedicar tu vida
dese cuenta que es una pregunta bastante
difícil yo no sé si todos ustedes
decidieron a que van a dedicar sus vidas
quizás es una pregunta muy amplia quizás
uno dedica solamente partes de su vida a
ciertas cosas o momentos de tu vida
yo espero darles algunas ideas que
fundamentan las decisiones que yo he
tomado y yo espero finalizar
manifestando mi intención la mía de
otros compañeros que están aquí
presentes de
comprometernos
a un activismo sostenido en el tiempo en
nuestras comunidades
a colaborar a construir con nuestros
conciudadanos en nuestra ciudad una
visión compartida de nuestra ciudad esto
es algo que nosotros necesitamos que es
importante sentimos que es algo que es
necesario hacerlo y nosotros hemos
decidido asumir ese compromiso
yo hoy soy docente soy maestro soy
profesor de ciencias y matemáticas
soy profesor en el mismo colegio donde
yo estudié hace 20 años
y miren que ser profesor es algo
complejo de verdad explicárselo a
personas que no han sido profesores
antes
difícil
sin importar el grado que tú enseñas o
la materia que tú
en señas
todos los profesores tienen una misma
labor una labor compartida en todas las
diferentes culturas y sociedad es una
labor de traspasar los valores las
habilidades las creencias acumuladas en
el tiempo en el pasado hacia el futuro
pasarlo hacia una nueva generación
usted cree en que yo quería ser profesor
cuando yo estaba estudiando la verdad
que no la verdad que si le soy sincero
yo no puedo decir que es mi vocación la
verdad es que yo cuando estudiaba tenía
grandes ambiciones para mí mismo mis
planes como de muchos de mis compañeros
en aquella época de los 90 era irnos del
país hacer nuestra vida y conseguir
nuestros éxitos en otras sociedades y de
hecho mi familia se dedicó a darme la
educación y darme las oportunidades para
que eso fuese posible mi familia y yo lo
agradezco y logra ser toda mi vida me
dio a mí una educación de la más alta
calidad posible y eso me permitió a mí
tener opciones y con estas opciones yo
tomé decisiones y yo decidí irme
fue después con el tiempo que yo empecé
a cuestionar las decisiones que había
tomado cuestiones por las razones por
qué tomó esas decisiones
y de 50 yo como profesor parte de mi
trabajo es parte de mi trabajo es that
decirles a mis alumnos darles indicios
indicaciones señales de qué hacer con
sus vidas de cómo tomar esa decisión y
no soy yo solamente son sus familias es
el colegio son las iglesias es toda una
sociedad trabajando en esto
profesor profesional
profesión todas son palabras que tienen
una misma raíz todas son palabras que
vienen de la palabra profesar
profesar sé que es una palabra un poco
que no se utiliza ya tanto verdad
es una palabra quizás
de otra época cuando éramos más
religiosos cuando teníamos que decir
públicamente nuestras creencias tenemos
que pararnos en público y prometer ante
todos que nosotros nos vamos a dedicar a
algo
a disculpa
yo como profesor de ciencias de
matemáticas tengo un inmenso privilegio
yo todos los años
vuelvo a repasar el esfuerzo inmenso que
hizo la humanidad para acumular ciertas
verdades ciertas verdades sobre el
universo ciertas verdades sobre la
naturaleza verdades de las cuales
estamos muy seguros de las cuales yo
tengo inmensa confianza cuando les
enseño a mis alumnos de lo cierto de esa
verdad la ley de gravedad el teorema de
pitágoras son todas cosas que cuando yo
se las muestro mis alumnos yo no tuvo en
ningún momento de su verdad
y eso es un privilegio que tengo como
profesor de ciencias de matemáticas
porque el contenido que yo doy es un
contenido que yo estoy seguro de su
validez
pero al mismo tiempo me doy cuenta que
no es suficiente porque es el mismo
conocimiento que yo siempre tuve que mis
padres y mi familia se esforzó tanto en
que yo tuviese un descubrir un
conocimiento que es asombroso
y les digo que para mí son como joyas
que vienen del pasado
talladas por generaciones de hombres
creando cosas perfectas y bellas que son
niñas y después yo las comparto y las
paso hacia el futuro y para mí eso de
verdad es un honor y es una de las
muchas razones porque para mí ser
profesores es tan valioso
yo les muestro a ellos a mis alumnos les
muestro esta misma foto esta misma foto
que les muestro a ustedes que es una
foto de nuestro mundo de todo nuestro
mundo toda la historia todos los países
todas las culturas todos los humanos que
los humanos que han existido en toda la
historia del pasado han vivido en ese
planeta y esa es una foto de nuestro
mundo tomado desde nuestra luna
una foto que tomamos en 1968
antes de pisar la luna como tal
y yo les explico a mis alumnos
el esfuerzo tan inmenso que tomo ser
capaz de ir a la luna y tomar esa foto
sea como fueron siglos y diferentes
sociedades y civilizaciones
desarrollando ideas cuestionando esas
ideas proponiendo nuevas ideas hasta que
eventualmente en algún momento a
mediados del siglo 20 la humanidad
entera fue capaz de hacer ese inmenso
logro y yo les explico a mis alumnos que
con la ciencia y con las matemáticas yo
les puedo explicar cómo se hizo eso
cómo
pero no le puedo explicar por qué se
hizo eso ni para qué porque fuimos a la
luna y para qué fuimos a la luna
ahora no crean a mí me parece asombroso
saber cómo se logró eso como un cohete
llega hasta la luna cómo hacemos que
tres hombres no logren caminar sobre la
luna todas son cosas importantísimas
pero las clases de ciencias y
matemáticas no voy a ser capaz de
explicarlas a ellos porque lo hicimos ni
para que lo hicimos y eso es un problema
porque con las ciencias y las
matemáticas vamos a poder lograr
nuestros sueños y vamos a poder saber
cómo lograrlos pero no vamos a saber
porque soñar esos sueños y para que
soñamos esos sueños
yo aprovecho mis clases al darme cuenta
de esta falla tan grande yo aprovecho
mis clases para darles mencionar otras
ideas otras
que no son ideas tan válidas que son
cosas que son cuestionables que no son
temas para clases de ciencias y
matemáticas son quizás conocimientos y
verdades que conseguimos en otras
tradiciones de las humanas humanas
acumuladas
como la mitología la filosofía la
religión el arte la literatura la
historia la política entonces me encanta
echarles cuentos
cuentos que mi propio padre me echaba a
mí cuando yo era pequeño cuentos de
civilizaciones antiguas de los antiguos
griegos hace 2500 años y de sócrates y
sus alumnos la secuencia de grandes
alumnos que él tuvo después y apenas la
ciudad donde ellos vivieron
les recuerdo a mis alumnos lo que
sócrates les enseñó a sus alumnos que lo
más importante era tener una actitud de
humildad intelectual que el peor error
que podemos cometer en la vida es creer
que lo sabemos todo que lo correcto es
tener una actitud que usted deseen saber
a esta frase verdad yo lo que sé es que
no sé nada se lo han escuchado
en la antigua grecia había un oráculo el
oráculo de delfos y ese oráculo tenía
una gran recomendación una gran
recomendación para todos los griegos y
una recomendación que yo mismo le repito
a mis alumnos la recomendación era que
en la vida así lo conozcas del mundo así
no conozcas del universo mínimo debes
conocerte a ti mismo mínimo tienes que
tener una visión clara de tus valores de
tus deseos de lo que te gusta de lo que
no te gusta de lo que quieres de lo que
no quieres eso tienes que tenerlo tú
claro con respecto a ti mismo quizás no
sepas de otras personas que sea no sepas
de otros lenguajes otros países quizá no
sepa nada de ciencia y matemática pero
mínimo deberías conocerte a ti mismo muy
bien
a mí me gusta echar el cuento de roma'
y como romá se convirtió en el imperio
que conocimos me encanta estar en
cuentos de horacio de horacio sobre el
puente el cuento de un hombre que tiene
que decidir sacrificarse para defender a
su ciudad
una rama joven una roma pequeña mucho
antes de ser un gran imperio esa roma
estaba asediada por sus enemigos estaban
listos para invadir la y este hombre
horacio decide darle tiempo a sus
ciudadanos parándose en el puente entre
los enemigos y él dice una frase que es
famosa hoy en día
de qué manera de qué mejor manera se
puede morir un hombre que enfrentando
grandes adversidades defendiendo las
cenizas de sus padres y los templos de
sus dioses
si ahora yo les digo a ellos que esas no
son nuestra cultura quizás no es nuestra
civilización que esos cuentos y esas
historias son de esas sociedades que
esos son los cuentos que esos profesores
me echaban a sus alumnos y eran cuentos
que tenían
dentro de ellos la moraleja y los
valores que esa sociedad quería
promoverlo a su nueva generación
a mí me encanta echar el cuento de clic
a mes
el camp es el rey de uruk y saben que
este es el cuento más antiguo de la
historia es un cuento que ya tiene más
de 4500 años este cuento es más antiguo
que el alfabeto es más antiguo que la
biblia este cuento ya era una leyenda
antes de que se construyeran las
pirámides
este cuento el cuento la leyenda de
griega mes se relataba y se escribía en
tabletas de barro en mesopotamia
donde se fundaron las primeras ciudades
en el mundo las primeras ciudades que
existieron en el mundo se fundaron ahí y
brooke llegó a ser la más grande y
gloriosa de esas ciudades
y la leyenda the greek mamés se traspasó
por miles de años hasta hoy en día y
para mí es muy importante tanto que en
esta charla que yo tengo que decir
muchas otras cosas
4no mi tiempo para contarles esto pero
no lo voy al encuentro completo
digame ser un pésimo rey todos sus
súbditos lo detestaban a pesar de que él
era joven y fuerte y bello inteligente
porque era mitad dios
el como era mitad humano también tenían
las fallas de los humanos pues no era
ambicioso era arrogante era orgulloso
era terco era vanidoso lo cierto es que
esto es una combinación super peligrosa
porque una cosa es tener poder y otra
cosa es tener el poder y ser
irresponsable con él
con el tiempo que él gámez aprende y se
hace un mejor rey y se dedica su vida a
trabajar para ser aún una mejor ciudad
construyen los muros de la ciudad
canalizan el río y rica en los campos la
ciudad crece construyen infraestructuras
casas nuevas la ciudad crece más aún
pero bueno todos están felices todos
están contentos los súbditos están
contextos como enrique meza pero digamos
no está feliz
después de todo ese crecimiento de todo
ese
con 100 esa conciencia que él obtuvo él
se dio cuenta de un problema que él
tenía de que el pronto sin poder
evitarlo él se iba a morir como todos
los demás humanos y para él eso era un
gran problema
y saben que decide hacer y gámez decide
ir hasta donde los dioses a pedirles el
secreto de la inmortalidad imagínense el
orgullo que tiene este hombre su
confianza en sí mismo
y me deja su familia deja sus amigos
dejar sus proyectos dejar su ciudad se
va cruza los desiertos cruzan las
montañas y el camino es tan largo y el
camino es tan difícil que aún que es el
gran bíblicamente
se debilita se enferma se infla que s
los obstáculos lo envejecen
y ya cansado y enfermo y viejo y débil
ya me lo logra dígame si llega a la
tierra de los dioses pero antes de
llegar allá tiene que cruzar un río de
los muertos y tiene que pedirle un
barquero que lo ayude porque claro como
toda la vida nada se puede hacer solo no
y el barquero accede a ayudarlo llegas a
donde los dioses y carmen se le pide por
la inmortalidad los dioses se la otorgan
que la mente está todo feliz y gámez
convence al barquero a que nos lleve de
regreso a brooke para tener para
ahorrarse el viaje de regreso lo cierto
es que la mente está feliz contento va a
regresar a su ciudad con toda la gloria
va a ser joven de nuevo va a ser
inmortal
él le decide pedirle al barquero que se
pare
porque él quiere bañarse él quiere
ponerse bonito
él quiere vestirse correctamente antes
de regresar a su ciudad y él mientras
que está distraído preparándose para la
bienvenida tiene una culebra y una
culebra en silencio y glosa mente se
roba el secreto de la inmortalidad
y después de todo ese esfuerzo se queda
sin nada
se queda sin nada y está derrotado y
está cansado y está viejo y está débil y
el barquero le ofrece le dice bueno si
quieres te llevó de regreso para que les
vuelvan a pedir los dioses por de nuevo
y mismo puede en el reconoce que él ya
no puede aguantar esa aventura de nuevo
y entonces le pide al barquero que lo
lleve hasta brook y claro que gámez con
una pena inmensa porque ya no tiene nada
con qué pagarle porque es un viejo pobre
que no tiene nada con que pagar sus
deudas
pero y este es el final de la historia
cuando llegan a uruk gigamesh que está
preocupado porque no sabe con qué le va
a pagar al barquero se da cuenta que el
barquero está asombrado que el barquero
cuando vio el look se asombró
porque dice en cuenta ese barquero que
es el transporte entre los vivos y los
muertos de 50 es como una fuerza de la
naturaleza ese barquero nunca antes
había visto una ciudad
porque las ciudades no son producto de
la naturaleza la ciudad es un invento
nuestro y ese barquero nunca había visto
una y menos había visto a la grandiosa
uruk y mes se dio cuenta que si tenía
con qué pagarle glam esa garra y lo
invita le dice bate del barco y visita
mi ciudad camina conmigo sobre las
murallas de mi ciudad
camina y siéntate y vamos a contemplar
el esplendor de uruk
sí porque yo he hecho estos cuentos
porque yo he hecho estos cuentos mis
alumnos porque él ha hecho estos cuentos
ustedes la verdad que yo no quiero
llegar a una conclusión definitiva no lo
vamos a poder hacer en 13 minutos 15
minutos
mi intención es darle a ustedes una
visión panorámica
los valores y la forma en que esos
valores se transmitían en el pasado y yo
quiero decirles que como profesor lo veo
la forma en que los jóvenes están
continuamente buscando respuestas para
estas preguntas respuestas que el busque
de su propia sociedad respuestas que
buscan en su familia y sus respuestas
que quizás para nosotros es difícil
y tenerlas
de 50 vivimos en un mundo que está
cambiando vertiginosamente y cada vez
cambia más rápido las tradiciones
milenarias que
hemos acumulado en el tiempo quizás no
sean óptimas para el futuro
y yo me pregunto a mí mismo yo sé a lo
que yo voy a dedicar mi vida yo tengo la
capacidad de decirle a otras personas a
que dedicar su vida al final la
conclusión es que yo formó a mis alumnos
y les doy herramientas para que ellos
decidan a qué dedicar su vida
cada decisión
es un sacrificio
cuando tú escoges hacer algo dejas de
hacer otra cosa
cuando tú ves conocerte a ti mismo
requiere la confianza de poder verte en
el espejo y verte tal como eres y no
voltear la cara y no desear irte y ver
otras cosas sino poder quedarte y verte
en el espejo ver tu retrato y sentirlo
reconocerte a ti mismo y reconocer como
eres entonces para mí es muy importante
este señor rafael cadenas él es un
profesor no solamente un profesor él es
un profesor él es alguien que dedicó su
vida a una gran labor a un oficio de ser
poeta y toda su vida es todo esfuerzo
que él hizo tuvo un gran fruto un fruto
que hoy es reconocido en todo el mundo y
por todos nosotros
a pesar de estar muy contento con la
forma la decisión que él tomó en
dedicarse a la poesía
es obvio por esa cita que no está muy
feliz cuando él se ve en el retrato de
nuestra sociedad y de nuestra ciudad
para mí de verdad que a lo que yo quiera
llegar al final a cabo
yo y un grupo de personas que muchos
están aquí presentes
hemos decidido comprometernos con
nuestra ciudad quizás principalmente
para no decir eso cuando yo tenga la
edad de cadenas para no decir cuánto
debe andar mal en nosotros porque yo
quiero verme en un retrato en el retrato
de mi sociedad de mi ciudad y yo quiero
sentirme lleno de orgullo
para nosotros
este mundo grande y complejo este mundo
inmenso lleno de siete mil millones de
personas de diferentes culturas y
valores y creencias donde cada uno de
esos seres humanos tienen que decidir a
qué va a dedicar su vida y toma esa
decisión a base de consideraciones
económicas de valores religiosos de lo
que las demás personas piensan y para mí
es muy importante que todos reconozcamos
que vivimos en un tiempo donde es muy
difícil saber lo que debemos hacer el
vivimos en un tiempo donde la frase de
sócrates es más útil que nunca todos
debemos reconocer que lo que sabemos es
muy poco y tenemos que dedicar nuestro
tiempo a pensar a pensar a estudiar a
unirnos a conversar y a pensar sobre los
valores que queremos pasar a las nuevas
generaciones ahora para mí en todo ese
mundo hay un pedacito de ese mundo que
es mío del cual yo soy responsable que
es la sociedad que a mí me género es
donde mis padres se criaron y donde yo
fue el colegio donde yo aprendí a hablar
y esa región
y esa ciudad es mi ciudad es nuestra
ciudad
y para nosotros
hemos decidido empezar esta iniciativa
que ya tiene varios años pero cada vez
se está haciendo cada vez más grande en
un intento de formar un equipo de
personas en la ciudad dedicadas al
desarrollo de la misma dedicadas a
construir juntos una visión de ciudad
para nosotros una ciudad que nosotros
nos pueda llenar de orgullo para
nosotros en este momento y ya voy a
terminar disculpen esto para nosotros
este momento lo más importante el
proyecto fundamental es el desarrollo el
reconocimiento del valor de los espacios
de los cerros y las filas de nuestra
ciudad
ver lo bello que son esas filas dicen
cuenta mi intención es por lo menos
estar en la situación de william es que
si cuando yo sea viejo y no tengan nada
con qué pagarle al barquero por lo menos
pueda traerlo a mi ciudad para
mostrarles lo que yo hice cuando era
joven y fuerte
muchas gracias